[Music]
my guest tonight is a comedian a
musician and actor and a poet and he's
only 23 years old I just found that out
I did not know he was so young and I now
resents him his new special what is
available on YouTube and Netflix please
welcome my good friend Bo Burnham
[Applause]
[Music]
no boom-boom that would be that was the
widest thing we've ever done I think and
then the seats were a little lower I
know he likes a bit of a you want him to
be here yeah yeah but we're on eye level
both of you were both you and I are tall
that's weird I specifically asked to be
always higher than the cap you you've
heard like obviously oh you're tall you
play basketball you got a lot I finally
heard the comeback it's not mine but
it's uh so give me it give me it
hey Bo you're tall do you play
basketball no do you play mini golf
are you a jockey can I tell you
something or your parents short when I
first started doing Santa because you
have nothing to talk about cuz you're a
young boy you're like in a smoke-filled
nightclub like hey you got nothing to
say I would have to address my height
and I would say people always ask me
because I'm tall if I play basketball
mine is worse I go I always say hey your
face shizzle up do you box it was me
yeah yeah it was before I hadn't found
my way it's so hard you have to get that
laugh up top another one is do they say
how's the weather up there and you say
it's raining and you spit in their face
I will say never no disadvantage to
being tall yeah oh what'd you think I
would do anything to be like I'm six
five six six that's what a good day I
want to be like I do anything just like
like six one six two really yeah why
what's wrong I don't know I feel like
I'm just I'm just getting into a sort of
freak dumber like like airplane tell you
I fly a lot in airplanes or hugging my
knees yeah I when I hit puberty in high
school segues when I had purely in high
school I grew so quickly I grew like six
inches my sophomore year and I had
stretch marks on my spine from growing
so fast and I was in theater and I told
my theater friends that it was like a
girl likes having to scratch my back for
a fact but they're like thick brown like
bear claws but we were theater gets me
to know another difference she was
getting real yeah
[Music]